have you noticed that it's been quite
some time since Google hit a home run
almost everything they've launched
basically since Chrome back in 2008 has
fallen flight of expectations or been a
complete failure this includes Google
Plus Google Glass Google cardboard
Google Fiber Google Nexus Google allo
and most recently Google bard but that's
not just these new product launches that
aren't going Google's way either even
their hero products are starting to lose
steam many people are switching to Edge
Bing and chat GPT instead of chrome
Google and Bard more people than ever
are also switching from Gmail to Outlook
or even a third-party option like
protonmail and as for Android well the
iPhone has been annihilating Android in
terms of market share over the past 10
years even YouTube one of their goals
and gooses has started to show a few
signs of weakness as Revenue fell for
three quarters in a row Google has been
aware of this shortcoming for quite some
time now and their solution was just
Brute Force
just keep launching new products and
entering new sectors with initiatives
like Google TV and stadia and YouTube
shorts and hope that something ends up
sticking but unfortunately nothing has
really stuck at least not in the mega
scale that you would expect with the
giant like Google amongst this graveyard
of failures and the disappointment
though there does seem to be one glimmer
of hope Google Cloud it looks like
Google has taken a page straight out of
Microsoft's Playbook when consumer
products don't work out because of
public perception or too much baggage or
whatever just switch to offering
Enterprise Products as businesses are
far more logical they just care about
the product and the price your story and
ethics is no concern to them as long as
it doesn't affect their business
but unlike Microsoft to enter the cloud
scene and mid strides in the early 2010s
Google has had an extraordinarily
difficult time breaking in in fact they
were losing billions of dollars trying
to chase the cloud Market until the
beginning of this year when they posted
their first ever profit and considering
that 50 of all of Google's current job
openings are for cloud roles I'd say
that it's safe to say that Google is
very much doubling down on the
Enterprise Cloud business
so join me as we take a look at Google's
Monumental shift from being a ubiquitous
consumer business to being an Enterprise
juggernaut
taking a look back the story of Google
Cloud takes us back to March of 2006 to
the launch of AWS or Amazon web services
AWS would eventually grow to be the gold
standard when it comes to the cloud
virtually every esteemed company that
you can think of has adopted AWS
including Airbnb McDonald's twitch
Twitter epic games and even Netflix and
Disney in fact some analysts estimate
that AWS accounts for a trillion dollars
worth of Amazon's market cap this means
that their massive retail operation that
everyone actually knows about is only
worth a few hundred billion dollars or a
mere fraction of their entire valuation
but when Amazon launched AWS they were
by no means trying to create the next
big thing in fact the launch of AWS was
more of a desperate move than a
calculated one Amazon's retail business
simply wasn't earning a profit and with
funding drying up due to the.com crash
they needed another source of Revenue
their solution was rather simple rent
doctors pair servers and databases but
this somehow turned into a trillion
dollar business Google was watching all
of this play out in real time and
naturally they felt that they could do
it better as such in April of 2008
Google would enter the cloud scene with
the launch of app engine app engine had
a pretty ambitious offer make it easier
than ever for developers to launch
websites by leveraging the power of
Google's infrastructure they largely
simplified the process of deploying code
and managing traffic spikes in fact they
completely removed these concerns from
the equation as they would handle this
stuff from their end but not only was
Google trying to make app engine as easy
to use as possible but they were also
trying to make it as cheap as possible
in fact the original version didn't even
have a paid option everyone got a
generous free quota to mess around and
test with and naturally given that this
was from Google they attracted a lot of
developer twenty thousand to be precise
one month later they would open up the
service to all developers and 10 months
after that they would add paid tiers to
app engine but something was off app
engine was by far the easiest to use and
the cheapest especially from a big tech
company but for some reason developers
just weren't sticking around this was
extremely confusing Google had used this
same strategy time and time again it
usually took great success offering a
better service for a cheaper price or
free was literally the bread and butter
of the entirety of Google so why in the
world weren't developers joining up in
the masses well the reality was that
Google had gotten the developer
Community completely wrong which is
rather ironic given that Google
themselves is just a bunch of developers
the problem was that in order to make
the service as easy to use as possible
Google had to sacrifice a lot of
customizability and prefer performance
for Google to deliver on the ease of use
aspect they had to shrink the infinite
developer landscape into a few succinct
boxes because frankly they could only
address so many sectors also remember
how app engine launched with only a free
tier well that tier was indeed generous
for testing but it was completely
impractical for production applications
combine this with CPU limitations
scaling issues and slow response times
and developers were out before app
engine was even fully launched the OG
Google though wasn't afraid to keep
trying despite failure so it was only a
matter of time until they put out a new
offering
a year after the launch of app engine
Google would have added Java support but
this didn't change much as this
developer put it there are a couple of
fundamental issues that must be
addressed and addressed properly before
Google app engine can be taken seriously
as a web application platform and to
know Java support is most definitely not
one of them Google saw this and said
alright then if it's not Java they want
maybe it's cloud storage no bigquery and
prediction apis no Cloud SQL no
um 24 7 phone support no PHP support no
encryption still no not enough Google's
additions to their Cloud offerings over
the next five years really did that much
to attract the big boys
the bottom line was that the consumer
approach did not work with the
developers and the Enterprise customers
Google was trying to offer a
watered-down version that was cheap and
easy to use when developers preferred a
fully customizable option which they
were more than happy to pay for so
ironically Amazon's Bare Bones offering
that was infinitely customizable was
actually far more appealing than
Google's watered-down assortment
this was super frustrating Google was
literally trying to create a new
developer offering that was easier and
more convenient than anything else on
the market but for some reason
developers prefer the less convenient
stuff
disappointed Google would turn back to
what they were good at the consumer
market and with that we would see the
launch of Google Drive on April 24 2012.
in classic Google fashion they launched
with 5 gigabytes of free storage which
quickly grew to 15 gigabytes and the
drive would take off
within three years they would grow to 1
million pen users by 2017 and they would
reach a milestone of story over 2
trillion piles and by 2018 they would
reach 1 billion active users by all
accounts Google Drive was a massive
success but Google couldn't help but
feel that they had missed out on the
larger pie the Enterprise Market
sure reaching 1 billion users directly
was great but with a cloud operation
like AWS they could literally reach
trillions of users across hundreds of
ubiquitous platforms this feeling was
only made it worse by Microsoft and
their surprising success with Azure
which came out years after app engine
also Microsoft wasn't trying to do
anything revolutionary with Azure like
Google was their entire pitch was
basically just here's AWS but for
cheaper Google was Furious and in 2014
they decided that if they couldn't fight
their way to the top they were going to
buy their way to the top this plan was
through folder on one side they would
literally buy out smaller Cloud
providers and their users like with
Firebase on the other side they would
subsidize their Cloud offerings by a
ridiculous amount in fact they would
slash prices of all Cloud offerings
between 30 and 85 percent
surely this was a deal that was simply
too good to refuse until customers
refused
the harsh reality was that no company
was taking Google's offering seriously
moreover they saw no reason to switch
when there were already two great
offerings AWS and Azure one that was
focused on performance and the one that
was focused on price
Google just didn't fit in the picture
and now that they had largely cut prices
they were burning ridiculous amounts of
money during the worst of it they were
losing five and a half billion dollars
per year on cloud alone so Underwood it
desperately tried to convince investors
that Google Cloud should be judged based
on growth instead of financials but
investors weren't convinced as the
growth wasn't even all that remarkable
compared to the real winners in the
first place
to make things worse this was the era in
which all of Google's new consumer
offerings would also start flopping
Google needed change and they needed it
fast enter Thomas kurian
to be honest Google got extraordinarily
lucky with Thomas kurian if you're not
familiar with Thomas that's
understandable as he spent most of his
career in the background but that isn't
to say that his contributions were
anything short of extraordinary after
working a few years as a consultant
early on in his career Thomas joined
Oracle in 1996 and over the next 12
years he would work his way all the way
up to president Dev Oracle reporting
directly to oracle's founder and CEO
Larry Ellison Thomas was like the dream
candidate for Google as he had literally
spent his entire career building up the
biggest Enterprise tech company in the
world Oracle he was in charge of 35
000 developers DACA billion dollar
budgets and was basically the de facto
CEO of Oracle Cloud but while Thomas was
the perfect candidate to lead Google
Cloud Google really had a no shot at
getting him for starters why would he
want to leave the world's most
successful Enterprise tech company where
he was already the main AI to go lead
these struggling Google Cloud it makes
no sense whatsoever if you're thinking
that Google could just bribe him with
money this is also false because he has
no need for money we always talk about
how Google is a top paying employer and
house on their pitche is the highest
paid employee in the world but all I can
say is that Thomas has already been
there and done that in fact Thomas was
the world's fifth highest paid Tech
executive way back in 2010 before Sunder
was even a thing and by 2018 Thomas was
earning just under 100 million dollars
per year so at this point all that was
left for Thomas was to become AC Suite
executive or even CEO potentially earn
even more than Sunder piche worked for
another 10 years in a familiar
comfortable environment and retire as an
oracle Legend but obviously things
didn't play out that way that's why
we're even talking about Thomas you see
around the same time that Google
desperately needed help Thomas and Larry
would get into a massive argument over
the future of Oracle Cloud Thomas felt
that Oracle should run more of their
software on AWS and Azure to reach as
many customers as possible while Larry
felt that they should be an oracle
software on their own cloud to bolster
the usage of Oracle Cloud this pretty
disagreement would quickly be blown out
of proportions and on September 28 2018
Thomas would announce that he was
resigning from Oracle and that he was
actively searching for New Opportunities
this was straight up a blessing from God
for Google during a time in which they
needed more help than ever before one of
the most qualified Cloud Executives in
the entire world was looking for a job
likely the only people in the entire
world who are more qualified than Thomas
were Andy Jazzy not the CEO of Amazon
and mark russonovich the CTO of azure so
Google lucked out with the third best
option in the entire world out of
nowhere yeah I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that Thomas would be
hired as a Google Cloud CEO at these
star part of 2019 but it was by no means
a smooth road ahead as Thomas was
literally taking over a money pit
[Music]
Thomas says that the main issue at
Google Cloud wasn't that hard to spot
once he joined the problem was that
Google was focused on creating
sophisticated Technologies when the key
was to build a straightforward reliable
Solutions so the first order of business
was Shifting the mindset from where a
tech company to where a Solutions
company as such instead of hiring a
bunch of developers Thomas would hire a
bunch of sales engineers and solutions
Architects these guys are in charge of
engaging with current and new customers
and addressing all of their questions
and concerns regarding how Google can
accomplish what they're hoping for to
really solidify this mindset shift
Thomas would also acquire Some
up-and-coming Cloud companies his most
notable Acquisitions were a looker for
2.6 billion and a mandiant for 5.4
billion all of these internal changes
helped tremendously in terms of product
development and sales but likely
Thomas's biggest play was finding a new
distinguishing Factor as we previously
touched on AWS is desired for its
performance Azure is desired for its
price and the Google always trying to be
desired for it ease of use but what they
figured out the hard way was that
developers don't actually care about
ease of use all that much if it comes at
the cost of performance or
customizability so what Google needed
was a new distinguishing factor and
that's when Thomas stumbled upon the
open source Cloud Market open source
platforms like mongodb and elasticsearch
were not only having trouble competing
against the likes of AWS but they were
actively being attacked by the likes of
AWS and Azure seeing this Thomas knew
exactly what their distinguishing Factor
would be they would be the champion of
an open source Cloud Solutions with that
he would form a partnership with seven
of the most popular open source
Solutions this gave developers the
tremendous power of the Google
infrastructure as well as the insane
freedom and customization offered by
these open source platforms and that was
it that was the turning point which
finally started attracting large client
including coinbase Deutsche Bank for the
General Mills and SpaceX in fact Google
cloud is now performing even better than
their ad business which has become
stagnant Google Cloud now also accounts
for one-fourth of Google's entire
Workforce and judging by their open
roles they're only looking to grow this
bigger and speaking of growing bigger
they have plenty of space to do so as
they still only control about 10 percent
of this Market all of this brings us
back to Google's original issue which is
that none of the recent consumer
products have been sticking and their
existing ones are starting to lose steam
this is not a good omen for any company
but luckily for Google it seems like
they have built out a solution to grow
past their consumer days just like
Microsoft did a decade ago so while
Google's future in the consumer Market
is indeed looking Bleak their future in
the Enterprise Market is looking
brighter than ever and that's why the
cloud is the future of Google
speaking of consumer products that are
losing Steam Chat gpd's accuracy has
really fallen off a cliff check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one